The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today's lecture
is about a brand new data
structure that you've
probably seen before,
and we've mentioned
earlier in double 06,
called a binary search tree.
We've talked about
binary search.
It's a fundamental divide
and conquer paradigm.
There's a data structure
associated with it,
called the BST, a
binary search tree.
And what I want to do is
motivate this data structure
using a problem.
It's a bit of a toy problem,
but certainly a problem
that you could imagine
exists in all sorts
of scheduling problems.
It's a part of a runway
reservation system
that you can imagine building.
And what I'll do is
define this problem
and talk about how we could
possibly solve it with the data
structures you've already seen--
so lists and arrays, heaps
as well as, which
we saw last time--
and hopefully motivate you into
the reason behind the existence
of binary search
trees, because they
are kind of the
perfect data structure
for this particular problem.
So let's dive into what the
runway reservation system looks
like.
And it's your basic
scheduling problem.
We'll assume an airport
with a single runway.
Now Logan has six runways.
But the moment there's any sort
of weather you're down to one.
And of course, there's lots of
airports with a single runway.
And we can imagine that
this runway is pretty busy.
There's obviously safety issues
associated with landing planes,
and planes taking off.
And so there are
constraints associated
with the system, that
have to be obeyed.
And you have to build these
constraints in-- and the checks
for these constraints--
into your data structure.
That's sort of the
summary of the context.
So reservations
for future landings
is really what this
system is built for.
There's a notion of time.
We'll assume that
time is continuous.
So it could be represented
by a real variable,
or a real quantity.
And what we'd like to do is
reserve requests for landings.
And these are going to
specify landing time.
Each of them is going to
specify a landing time.
We call it t.
And in particular,
we're going to add t
to the set R of landing times if
no other landings are scheduled
within k minutes.
And k is a parameter
that could vary.
I mean, it could be statically
set to 3 minutes, or maybe 4.
You can imagine it
varying it dynamically
depending on weather
conditions, things like that.
For the most of the examples
we'll talk about today,
we'll assume k is 3 minutes,
or something like that.
So this is about adding
to the data structure.
And so an insert
operation, if you will,
that has a constraint associated
with it that you need to check.
And so you wouldn't insert if
the constraint was violated.
You would if the
constraint was satisfied.
And time, as I
said, is something
that is part of the system.
It needs to be modeled.
You have the current
notion of time.
And every time you have a
plane that's already landed,
which means that
you can essentially
take this particular
landing time away
from the set R. So this
removal, or delete-- we remove
from set R, which is
the set of landing times
after the plane lands.
So every once in awhile,
as time increments,
you're going to be checking
the data structure.
And you can do this, maybe,
every minute, every 30 seconds.
That isn't really important.
But you have to be able
to remove from this data
structure.
So fairly straightforward
data structure.
It's a set, R. We don't quite
know how to implement it yet.
But we'd like to do all of these
operations in order log n time,
where n is the size of the set.
All right?
So any questions about that?
Any questions about
the definition
of the problem
before we move on?
Are we good on?
OK.
So let's look at a real
straightforward example,
and put this up here so you
get a better sense of this.
Let's say that, right
now, we are at time 37.
And the set R has
41.2, 49, and 53 in it.
And that's time.
Now you may get a request
for landing time 53.
And-- I'm sorry.
I want to call this
56.3-- 41.2, 49, and 56.3.
You may get a request
for landing time 53.
And right now the time is 37.
It's in the future, and
you say OK because you've
done the check.
And let's assume
that k equals 3.
And 53 is four ahead of 49, and
3.3 before 56.3, so you're OK.
44 is not allowed.
It's too close to 41.2.
And 20, just for
completeness, is not
allowed because it's passed.
Can't schedule in the past.
I mean, it could
be the next day.
But then you
wouldn't call it 20.
Let's assume that time is
a monotonically increasing
function.
You have a 64-bit number.
It can go to the end
of the world, or 2012,
or wherever you want.
So you can keep the
number a bit smaller,
and do a little constant
factor optimization, I guess.
So that's sort of the set up.
And hopefully you get a sense
of what the requirements.
And you guys know about a bunch
of data structures already.
And what I want to do is
list each one of them,
and essentially shoot
them down with respect
to not being able to make
this efficiency requirement.
And I'd like you guys to
help me shoot them down.
So let's talk about
an easy one first.
Let's say you have an unsorted
list or an array corresponding
to R. That's all you have.
What's wrong with
this data structure
from an efficiency standpoint?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Pretty much everything
you want to do to it is linear.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Pretty much everything you
want to do to it is linear.
And so you want to check
the k minute check.
You can certainly insert
into it, and just add to it.
So that part is not linear,
that's constant time.
But certainly,
anything where you
want to go check against
other elements of the array,
it's unsorted.
You have no idea of where
to find these elements.
You have to scan
through the entire array
to check to see whether
there's a landing time that's
within k of the current time
t that you're asking for.
And that's going to
take order n time.
So you can insert in
order 1 without a check.
But sadly, the check
takes order n time.
All right?
Let's do something that is
a little more plausible.
Let's talk about a sorted array.
So this is a little
more subtle question.
Let's talk about a sorted array.
What happens with
a sorted array?
Someone?
What can you do
with a sorted array?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do a binary search
to find the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Binary search
would find a bad insert.
OK, good.
So that's good.
So if you have a sorted array,
and just for argument's sake,
it looks like 4, 20, 32, 37, 45.
And it's increasing order.
And if you get a particular time
t, you can use binary search.
And let's say, in particular,
the time is, for example, 34.
Then what you do is you go
to the midpoint of the array,
and maybe you just look at that.
And you say oh, 34
is greater than 32.
So I'm going to go
check and figure out
if I need to move to
the left or the right.
And since it's greater I'm
going to move to the right.
And within logarithmic
time, you'll
find what we call the insertion
point of the sorted array,
where this 34 is
supposed to sit.
And you don't necessarily
get to insert there.
You need to look, once you've
found the insertion point,
to your left and to your right.
And do the k minute check.
So finish up the
answer to the question,
tell me how long it's going to
take me to find the insertion
point, how long it's going
to take me to do the check,
and how long it's going
to take me to actually do
the insertion.
AUDIENCE: Log n in the search--
PROFESSOR: Log n for the
search, to find the point.
AUDIENCE: Constant
for the comparison?
PROFESSOR: Constant
to the comparison.
And then the last step?
AUDIENCE: Do the
research [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry, little louder.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: The
insertion is constant.
PROFESSOR: Insertion
is constant?
Is that right?
Do you people agree with him,
that insertion is constant?
AUDIENCE: You've got a
maximum size up there, right?
There must be a maximum.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, the indices--
so right now the array
has indices i.
And if you start with 1, it's
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, et cetera.
So what do you
mean by insertion?
Someone explain to me
what-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: When you
put something in you
have to shift
every element over.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Ok, good, that's great.
I guess I should give
you half a cushion.
But I'll do the full one, right?
And you get one, too.
So the point here is
this is pretty close.
It's almost what we want.
There's a little bit
of a glitch here.
We know about binary search.
The binary search is
going to allow us,
if there's n elements
here, to find the place--
it's going to be able
to find-- and I'm
going to precise here-- the
smallest i such that R of i
is greater than or equal
to t in order log n time.
It's going to be
able to do that.
You're going to be able to
compare R of i and R of i
minus 1-- so the left
and the right-- against t
in order 1 time.
But sadly, the actual insertion
is going to require shifting.
And that could take order n
time, because it's an array.
So that's the problem.
Now you could imagine that
you had a sorted list.
And you could say, hey
if I have a sorted list,
then the list looks
like this, and it's
got a bunch of pointers in it.
And if I've found
the insertion point,
then-- the list is nice,
because you can insert something
by moving pointers
in constant time
once you've found
the insertion point.
But what's the
problem with the list?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can't do
binary search [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well you can't
do binary search on a list.
There's no notion of
going to the n by 2 index
and doing random access on
a conventional list, right?
So the list does
one thing right,
but doesn't do the
other thing right.
The array does a
couple things right,
but doesn't do the
shifting right.
And so you see why we've
constructed this toy problem.
It's to motivate the
binary search tree data
structure, obviously.
But you're close,
but not quite there.
What about heaps?
We talked about heaps last time.
What's the basic problem with
the heap for this problem?
The heaps are data
arrays, but you
can visualize them as trees.
And obviously if we're talking
about min heaps and max heaps.
So in particular, what goes
wrong with a min heap or a max
heap for this problem?
What takes a long time?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have to scan every
element, which [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I mean, sadly, you know when
we talk about min heaps or max
heaps, they actually have
a fairly weak invariant.
It turns out that-- I'm
previewing a bit here--
binary search
trees are obviously
similar to heaps in the
sense that you visualize
an array as a tree,
in the case of a heap.
And binary search
trees are trees.
But the invariant in a
min heap or a max heap,
is this kind of
a week invariant.
It essentially says,
look at the min element.
And the min element
has to be the root,
so you can do that one
operation pretty quickly.
But if you want to look
for a k minute check,
you want to see if there's
an element in the heap that
is less than or equal to k,
or greater than or equal to k
from t, this is going
to take order n time.
OK?
Good.
And finally, we haven't
talked about dictionaries,
but we will next week.
Eric will talk about hash
tables and dictionaries.
And they have the same problem.
So it's not like dictionaries
are going to solve the problem,
for those of you who know about
hash tables and dictionaries.
But you'll hear about
them in some detail.
They're very good
at other things.
So I don't want to say much more
about that, because you're not
supposed to know
about dictionaries.
Or at least we
don't want to assume
you do, though we
have talked about them
and alluded to
dictionaries earlier.
And so that's a story here.
Yeah, back there, question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, can you explain
why it's [INAUDIBLE] time?
PROFESSOR: So what
is a heap, right?
A heap essentially-- a
min heap, for example,
or we talked about
max heaps last time,
has the property that
you have an element k,
and you're going to look
at, let's say it's 21.
Let's do min heaps, so this
has to be less than what's
here, 23, and what
there, maybe it's
30, and so on and so forth.
And you have a
recursive definition.
And when you insert into a min
heap, typically what happens
is suppose you wanted to
insert, for argument's sake,
I want to insert 25.
I want to insert 25 into this.
The insertion algorithm
for a min heap
typically adds to the
end of the min heap.
So what you do is you
would add 25 to this.
And let's say that you
had something out here.
So you'd add to it.
And you'd start flipping things.
And you could work with
just this part of the array
to insert 25 in here.
And you'd be able to satisfy
the invariant of the min heap.
And you'd get a
legitimate min heap.
But you'd never check the
left part of it, which is 23.
So it's quite possible--
and this is a good example--
that your basic insertion
algorithm, which is essentially
a version of max heap
of i, or min heap of i,
would simply insert
at the end, and keep
flipping until you get
the min heap property,
would be unable to check
for the k minute check
during the insertion.
But what you'd have to do
is to go look elsewhere.
That min heap of i
we'd never look at--
or the insert algorithm we'd
never look at-- and that
would require order n time.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: So that's the
story for the min heap.
Thanks for the question.
And it's similar for
dictionaries, as I said.
And so we're stuck.
We have no data structure yet
that can do all of the things
that I put up on the board to
the left, in order log n time.
And as you can see, the
sorted array got pretty close.
And so if you could
just solve this problem,
if you could do fast insertion--
and by fast I mean order log n
time-- into a sorted
array, we'd be in business.
So that's what we'd like to
do with binary search trees.
Binary search trees
are, as you can imagine,
enable binary search.
But the sorted arrays
don't allow fast insertion,
but BSTs do.
So let me introduce BSTs.
As with any data
structure, there's
a nice invariant
associated with BSTs.
The invariant is stronger
than the heap invariant.
And actually, that makes them
a different data structure, not
necessarily a better
data structure.
And I'll say why, but different.
For this problem they're better.
So one example of a binary
search tree looks like this.
And as a binary tree you have
a node, and we call it x.
Each of the nodes
has a key of x.
So 30 is the key for this node,
17 for that one, et cetera.
Unlike in a heap,
your data structure
is a little more complicated.
The heap is simply
an array, and you
happen to visualize
it as a tree.
The binary search
tree is actually
a tree that has
pointers, unlike a heap.
So it's a more complicated
data structure.
You need a few more bytes for
every node of the binary search
tree, as opposed
to the heap, which
is simply an array element.
And the pointers
are parent of x.
I haven't bothered
showing the arrows here,
because you could be going
upwards or backwards.
And you could imagine
that you actually
have a parent pointer
that goes up this way,
and you have a child
pointer that goes this way.
So there's really,
potentially, three pointers
for each node, the
parent, the left child,
and the right child.
So pretty straightforward.
That's the data
structure in terms
of what it needs to have
so you can operate on it.
And there's an
invariant for a BST.
What makes a BST
is that you have
an ordering of the
key values that
satisfy the invariant that
for all nodes x if y is
in the left subtree
of x, we have--
if it's in the left
subtree then key of y
is less than or
equal to key of x.
And if y is in the
right subtree we
have key of y is greater
than or equal to key of x.
So if we're talking
about trees here,
subtrees here,
everything underneath--
and that's the stronger part
of the invariant in the BST,
versus in the heap we were just
talking about the children.
And so you look at
this BST, it is a BST
because if I look to
the right, from the root
I only see values that
are greater than 30.
And if I look to the left,
in the entire subtree,
all the way down I only see
values that are less than 30.
And that has to be true for any
intermediate node in the tree.
And the only other
nontrivial node here is 17.
And you see that 14 is less than
17, and 20 is greater than 17.
OK?
So that's the BST.
That's the data structure.
This is the invariant.
So let's look at why BSTs
are a possibility for solving
our runway reservation problem.
And what I'll do is
I'll do the insert.
So let's start with the
nil set of elements,
or null set of elements, R.
And let's start inserting.
So I insert 49.
And all I do is make a node
that has a key value of 49.
This one is easy.
Next insert, 79.
And what happens here
is I have to look at 49,
and I compare 79 to 49.
And because 79 is greater
than 49 I go to the right
and I attach 79 to
the right child of 49.
Then I want to insert 46.
And when I want to
insert 46 I look at this,
I compare 49 and 46.
46 is less, so I go to the left
side and I put 46 in there.
Next, let's say I
want to insert 41.
So far I haven't really talked
about the k minute checks.
And you could imagine
that they're being done.
I'll show you exactly, or
talk about exactly how they're
done in a second.
It's not that hard.
But let me go ahead
and do one more.
For 41, 41 is less
than 49, so I go left.
41 is less than 46, so
I go left and attach it
to the left child.
All right?
So that's what I have right now.
Now let's talk about
the k minute check.
It's good to talk about
the K minute check
when there's
actually a violation.
And let's assume
the k equals 3 here.
And so, same thing here.
You're essentially doing
binary search here.
And you're doing the checks as
you're doing the binary search.
So what you're
going to be doing is
you're going to check that--
you're going to compare 42
with 49, with the
k minute check.
And you realize they're 7 apart.
So that's OK.
And 42 is less than
49, so you go left.
And then you compare 42 with 46.
And again, it's less than 46,
but it's k away, more than 3
away from 46.
So that's cool.
And you go left.
And then you get to 41.
And you compare 42 with 41.
In this case is greater.
But it's not k more than it.
And so that means that if
you didn't have the check,
you would be putting 42 in here.
But because you have
the check, you fail.
And you say, look,
I mean this violates
the safety property, violates
the check I need to do.
And therefore I'm
not going to insert--
I'm not going to reserve
a request for you.
All right?
So what's happened here is
it's basically a sorted array,
except that you added
a bunch of pointers
associated with the tree.
And so it's somewhere between a
sorted list and a sorted array.
And it does exactly
the right thing
with respect to
being able to insert.
Once you've found
the place to insert,
it's merely attaching
this particular new node
with it's appropriate
key to the pointer.
All right?
So what's happened
here is that if h
is the height of the
tree then insertion
with or without the check
is done in order h time.
And that's what
BSTs are good for.
People buy that?
Any questions about how they
k minute check proceeded?
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So, what's it called?
The what check?
PROFESSOR: The k minute check.
Sorry, the k was 3 minutes k.
I had this thing over
here, add t to the set R
if no other landings are
scheduled within k minutes.
So k was just a number.
I want it to be a
parameter because it
doesn't matter what k is.
As long as you know what it is
when you do the binary search,
you can add that in to an
argument to your insert,
and do the check.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So in this case,
I set k to be 3 out here.
And I was doing a check
to see that the invariant,
any elements in the BST
already, on any nodes that
had keys that were
within 3 minutes--
because I fixed k to be
3-- to the actual time
that I was trying to insert.
All right?
AUDIENCE: So there's
no way [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
there's no way?
AUDIENCE: There's
no way you could
insert the 42 into
the tree then?
PROFESSOR: Well, if
the basic insertion
method into a binary search tree
doesn't have any constraints.
But you can certainly
augment the insertion method
without changing the efficiency
of the insertion method.
So let's say that
all you wanted to do
was insert into a
binary search tree,
and it had nothing to do
with the runway reservation.
Then you would just insert
the way I described to you.
The beauty of the
binary search tree
is that while you're
finding the place to insert,
you can do these checks--
the k minute checks.
Yeah, question back there.
AUDIENCE: What about 45?
PROFESSOR: What about 45?
So this is after-- we
haven't inserted 42
because it violated the check.
So when you do 45,
then what happens
is you see that
45 is less than 49
and you pass, because you're
more than 3 minutes away.
We'll stick with that example.
And then you get
here and then you
see that 45 is less than 46,
and you'd fail right here.
You would fail right here
if you were doing the check,
because 45 is not
3 away from 46.
All right?
So that's the story.
And so if you have h being
the height of the tree,
as you can see you're
just following a path.
And depending on
what the height is
you're going to do
that many operations,
times some constant factor.
And so you can say that
this is order h time.
All right?
Any other questions?
Yeah, question back there.
AUDIENCE: In a normal
array [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it's up to you.
In a conventional binary search
tree, or the vanilla binary
search tree, typically
what you're doing
is you're doing
either find or insert.
And so what that means
is that you would just
return the pointer
associated with that element.
So if you're looking for find
46, for example, on the tree
that I have out there, typically
46 is just the key value.
And there may be a record
associated with it.
And you would get a
pointer to that record
because it's already in there.
At that point you can
say I want to override.
Or if you want, you could
have duplicate values.
You could have this,
what's called a multiset.
A multiset is a set that
has duplicate elements.
In that case, you would need
a little more sophistication
to differentiate between
two elements that
have the same key values.
So you'd have to
call it 46a and 46b.
And you'd have to have some
way of differentiating.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
it be a problem
if the tree's not balanced?
PROFESSOR: Ah, great question.
Yes, stay tuned.
So I was careful, right?
I guess I kind of
alluded to the fact
that we'd solved the
runway reservation system.
Did I actually say that
we'd solved the problem?
Did I say we had
solved the problem?
OK, so I did not lie.
I did not lie.
I said that the height
of the tree was h.
And I said that this was
accomplished in order h time,
right?
Which is not quite what I want,
which is really your question.
So we'll get to that.
So we're not quite done yet.
But before we do
that, it turns out
that today's lecture is
really part one of two.
You'll get a really good
sense of BST operations
in today's lecture.
But there's going to be a few
things that-- we can't cover
all of double 6 in
the lecture, right?
We'd like to, and let you
off for the entire fall,
but that's not the way
it works, all right?
So it's a great question.
I'll answer it towards the end.
I just wanted you
to say a little bit
about other operations.
There's many operations that
you can do on a binary search
tree, that can be
done in order h time,
and some even in constant time.
And I'll put these in the notes.
Some of these are
fairly straightforward.
Find min can be done
in heap, in a min heap.
If you want to find the minimum
value, it's constant time.
You just return the root.
In the case of a binary search
tree, how do you find the min?
Someone?
Worth a cushion.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Keep
going to the left?
PROFESSOR: Keep
going to the left.
And how do you find the max?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Keep
going to the right.
All right great, thank you.
And finally, what
complexity is that?
I sort gave it away, but I
want to hear it from you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: It's the height
PROFESSOR: It's the
height, order h.
All right, it's
order h complexity.
Go to the left until
you hit a leaf,
and until leaf
order h complexity.
Same thing for max.
And then you can do
a bunch of things.
I'll put these in the notes.
You can find things
like next larger
x, which is the next
largest value beyond x.
And you look at the key for
x and you say, for example,
if you put 46 in there, what's
the next thing that's larger
and that?
In this tree here, it's 49.
But that's something which was
trivially done in this example.
But in general you can do
this in order h time as well.
And you can see the pseudocode.
And we'll probably cover
that in section tomorrow.
What I want to do today, for the
rest of the time I have left,
is actually talk about augmented
binary search trees, which
are things that can do more
and have more data in them
than just these pointers.
And that's actually
something which
should give you a sense of the
richness of the binary search
tree structure, this
notion of augmentation.
And those of you, again,
who have taken double 05,
you know about
design amendments.
And so specifications
never stay the same.
I mean, you're
working for someone,
and they never really
tell you what they want.
They might, but they
change their mind.
So in this case, we're
going to change our mind.
And so we've done
this to the extent
that we can cover all of
these in order h time.
And let's say that now
the problem specification
changed on us.
There's an additional
requirement
that we're asked to solve.
And so you sort of
committed to BST structures.
But now we have an
additional requirement.
And the new requirement is that
we be able to compute rank t.
And rank t is how
many planes are
scheduled to land at times
less than or equal to t.
So perfectly
reasonable question.
It wasn't part of
the original spec.
You now have built your
BST data structure,
you thought you were done.
Sorry, you aren't.
You've got to do
this extra stuff.
So that's the notion
of augmentation,
which we're going to use this
is an example of how we're
going to augment
the BST structure.
And oh, by the way,
I don't want you
to change the
complexity from order h.
And we eventually will
get to order log n,
but don't go change something
that was logarithmic to linear.
That would be bad.
So let's talk about
how you do this.
And I don't think we
need this anymore.
So the first thing we need to
do is add a little bit more
information to the
node structure.
And what we're going to do
is augment the BST structure.
And we're going to add one
little number associated
with each node, that looks at
the number of nodes below it.
So in particular,
let's say that I
have 49, 46, let's just
say 49, 46 for now.
And over here I
have 79, 64, and 83.
I'm going to modify--
I'm going to have
an extra number associated
with each of these nodes.
And I'm just going
to write that number
on the outside of the node.
And you can just imagine
that now the key value has
two numbers associated
with it-- the thing
that I write inside the node,
and what I write outside of it.
So in particular, when
I do insert or delete
I'm going to be
modifying these numbers.
And these are size numbers.
And what do I mean by that?
Well these numbers
correspond to subtree sizes.
So the subtree size
here is 1, 1, 1.
So as I'm building
this tree up I'm
going to create an
augmented BST structure,
and I've modified
insert and delete
so they do some extra work.
So let's say, for
argument's sake,
that I've added this in
sort of a bottom up fashion.
And what I have are these
particular subtree sizes.
All of these should make sense.
This has just a single
node, same thing here.
So this subtree sizes associated
with these nodes are all 1.
The subtree size
associated with 79
is 3, because you're
counting 79 and 64 and 83.
And the subtree size
associated with 49
is 5, because you're counting
everything underneath it.
How did we get these numbers?
Well you want to
think about this
as you started
with an empty set,
and you kept inserting into it.
And you were doing a sequence
of insert and delete operations.
And if I explain to you how
an insert operation modifies
these numbers, that is
pretty much all you need.
And of course, analogously,
for a delete operation.
So what would happen for, let's
say you wanted to insert 43?
You would insert
43 at this point.
And what you'd do is you
follow the insertion path
just like you did before.
But when you're
following that path
you're going to increment the
nodes that you're seeing by 1.
So you're going
to add 43 to this.
And you'd add 5 plus
1, because you see 49.
And then you would go
down and you'd see 46.
And so you'd add 1 to that.
And then finally,
you add 43 and you
assign-- since
it's a leaf-- you'd
assign to value corresponding
to the subtree size
of this new node that you
put in there, to be 1.
It guess a little, teensy
bit more complicated
when you want to do
the k minute check.
But from a complexity
standpoint,
if you're not worried
about constant factors,
you can just say, you know what?
I'm going to first run
the regular insert,
ignoring the subtree sizes.
And if it fails, I'm done.
Because I'm not going to
modify the BST, and I'm done.
I'm not going to have to
modify the subtree sizes.
If it succeeds, then
I'm going to go in,
and I know now that I can
increment each of these nodes,
because I know I'm
going to be successful.
So that's sort of a trivial
way of solving this problem,
that from an asymptotic
complexity standpoint
gives you your order
h augmented insert.
That make sense?
Now you could do something
better than that.
I mean, I would urge you,
if you had wrote something
that-- we asked you to
write something like this,
to create a single procedure
that essentially uses
a recursion appropriately to
do the right thing in one pass
through the BST.
And we'll talk about
things like that
as we go along in sections,
and possibly in lectures.
So that's the subtree
insert delete.
Everyone buy that?
Yeah, question back there.
AUDIENCE: If I wanted to delete
a number, like let's say 79--
PROFESSOR: Yep?
AUDIENCE: --would we
have to take it out
and then rewrite the entire BST?
PROFESSOR: What you'd have to
do is a bubble up pointers.
So you'd have to actually
have 64 connected to-- what
will happen is 83
would actually come up,
and you would essentially
have some thing-- this
is not quite how it works--
but 83 would move up
and you'd have 64 to the left.
That's what would happened
for delete in this case.
So you would have to move
pointers in the case of delete.
And we're not done with
binary search tree operations
from a standpoint of
teaching you about them.
We'll talk about them not
just in today's lecture,
but later as well.
So there's one
thing missing here,
though, which is I haven't
quite figured out--
I've told you how these
subtree sizes work.
But it's not
completely clear, this
is the last thing we have
to do, is how are you
going to compute rank t
from the subtree sizes?
So everyone understand
subtree sizes?
It's just the number of nodes
that are underneath you.
And you remember to count
yourself, all right?
Now what is rank t?
Rank t is how many
planes are scheduled
to land at times less
than or equal to t.
So now I have a BST structure
that looks like the one
and I just ended up with.
So I've added this 43.
And so let me draw
that out here,
and see if we can
answer this question.
This is a subtle question.
So I got 49, and that
subtree size is 6.
I got 46, subtree size is 2.
43, 79, 64.
and 83.
So what I want is
what lands before t?
And how do I do that?
Give me an algorithm
that would allow
me to compute in order h time.
I want to do this
in order h time.
What lands before t?
Someone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So first
you would have
to find where to insert
it, like we did before.
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: And then because we
have the order of whatever it
was before-- not
the order, the--
PROFESSOR: The sizes?
The sizes?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then we can
look what's more than it
on the right, we can
subtract it and we get--
PROFESSOR: What is more
than it on the right.
Do you want to say--
AUDIENCE: Because, like--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: --on the right--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --and then we
can take this minus this
and we get what's left.
PROFESSOR: That's
great, that's excellent.
Excellent.
So I'm going to do it a little
bit differently from what
you described.
I'm going to
actually do it in a,
sort of, a more positive
way, no offense intended.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to add up the things
that we want to add up.
And what you have
to do is walk--
your first step was right on.
I mean, your answer is correct.
I'm just going to do it
a little bit differently.
You walk down the tree
to find the desired time.
This is just your search.
We know how to do that.
As you walk down you
add in the nodes that
is the subtree sizes-- you're
just adding in the notes here.
So if you see-- depending
on the number of nodes
that you see as you're
going deeper in,
you want to add in the nodes.
And you're going to add
one to that, corresponding
to the nodes that are smaller.
And we're going to add in the
subtree sizes to the left,
as opposed to subtracting.
That may not make
a lot of sense.
But I guarantee you it
will once we do an example.
So what's going on here?
I want to find a
place to insert.
I'm not actually going
to do the insert.
Think of it is doing a lookup.
And along the way,
I need to figure out
the less than operator.
I want to find all
of the things that
are less than this
value I'm searching for.
And so I have to do
a bit of arithmetic.
So let's say that I'm
looking for what's
less than or equal to 79.
So t equals 79.
So I'm going to look at 49.
I'm going to walk down,
I'm going to look at 49.
And because I say I'm
looking at 49-- and 49
is clearly less than 79.
So I'm going to add 1.
And that's this check over here.
I move on and what I need to
do now is move to the right,
because 79 is greater than 49.
That's how my search would work.
But because I've
moved to the right,
I'm going to add the subtree
sizes that were to the left.
Because I know that all
of the things to the left
are clearly less than 79.
So I'm going to add 2,
corresponding to a subtree 46.
So I'm not actually
looking there.
But I'm going to add
all of that stuff in.
I'm going to move to the right,
and now I'm going to see 79.
At this point 79 is less
than or equal to 79.
So I'm going to see 79
and I'm going to add 1.
And because I've added 79,
just like I did with 49,
I have to add the subtree
size to the left of 79.
So the final addition
is I add 1 corresponding
to the subtree 64.
And at this point
I've discovered
where I have to insert, I've
essentially found the location,
it matches 79.
And there was no modification
required in this algorithm.
So if that was 78 you'd
essentially do the same things.
But you're done because you
found the value, or the place
that you want to insert.
And you've done a
bunch of additions.
And you go look at add 1, add
2, add 1, add 1, and you have 5.
And that's the
correct answer, as you
can see from this example.
So what's the bad news?
The bad news was what
this lady said up
front, which was we haven't
quite solved the problem.
Because sadly, I could
easily set things
up such that the height h is
order n, h could be order n.
And if, for example, I
gave you a sorted list,
and I said insert into
binary search tree
that's originally null 43,
and you put 43 in there.
Then I say insert 46.
And then I say instead of 48.
And then I say
insert 49, et cetera.
And, you know, these
could be any numbers.
Then you see that what
does this look like?
Does it look like a tree?
It looks like a list.
That's the bad news.
And I'll let Eric give
you good news next week.
We need to have this notion of
balanced binary search trees.
So everything I've said is true.
I did not lie.
But the one extra
thing is we need
to make sure these trees are
balanced so h is order log n.
And then everything
I said works.
All right?
See you next time.